I have of course been in Holland since I
last left st. Louis chess club in
December and Holland was cold I'm
telling you the month of March
I think they rewrote all the record
books since weather was kept
but as cold as it was in Holland one of
the hottest things that was happening in
the world of chess was the candidates
candidates tournament did you all manage
to follow some of those games and you
know what was going on Vladimir Kramnik
and Magnus Carlsen and I must say it
captured me and the game that I selected
tonight was a game that Vladimir Kramnik
is black he is one of the tournament
leaders as you know Vassily Ivanka quite
okay so we have to kind of put the
settings in proper order
Vladimir Kramnik is tied for first at +4
with his closest rival magnate Magnus
Carlsen also at +4 if the two players
make a draw Magnus Carlsen has the
higher tie breaks so Vladimir Kramnik
enters this round wit from the
perspective he's got to pull out all the
stops and he's got a win because Magnus
will play white against Peter Svidler
Vladimir is not expecting that Magnus
was with white is going to take too many
risks and lose the game and if Magnus
does make a draw and he Vladimir Kramnik
only draws with the black pieces well
Magnus becomes the Challenger so
Vladimir really feels that he has to win
and at the same time he's thinking to
himself well if I'm going all out for
the win over here maybe it will impact
Magnus to try to win himself so that's
another reason for
me playing very risky I bladder Mira's
opponent is a very mercurial Vasiliev on
Chuck
Meany Vanja can beat anybody on any
given day world champion or not equally
that Vasily could blow up one of the
weirdest things that happened in this
candidates tournament I mean I was just
overwhelmed five games five games lost
on time how do you do that like move you
know move so you know from Kramnik point
of view vasily is having a bad
tournament and he's vulnerable
okay so Yvonne Chuck opens up with 1.d4
hold on do I have the right yes d6 d4
Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 and we have the
perk defense well as it luck as your
good luck turns out to be I happen to be
a perk defense player I played the perk
the whole my whole life in fact in the
northwest we used to call it the rat the
rat we like the rat and I was influenced
very much by the games of Grandmaster
Duncan Suttles it was a grandmaster from
Canada who lives in Vancouver BC and I
very much like blacks defense so I
played the perk the rat much of my
career one of the things is is that it's
a very flexible system unfortunately
flexible for both sides white has a vast
array of meeting the perk defense to my
mind one of the most dangerous lines is
the so-called Austrian attack with f4
with a very straight idea of just
developing behind you know Knight f3
Bishop d3 castles and beat and
developing behind this broad array of
Hanz in the center also of course with
the idea of 'if I've many opponents have
played different moves against me I
recall one opponent vladakov osowiec he
played against me Bishop e2 variation
Bishop g7 and a completely different
type of attack g4 you know g5 get it
going you know off you go and that was a
fun game
I've had other players play against me a
more flexible system which was Bishop
III Bishop g7 Queen d2 the idea from
White's point of view with this setup is
obviously it's very clear he's preparing
to castle long and at the same time
White thinks that he could neutralize
this Bishop on g7 with a quick Bishop h6
and White's idea is if he provokes black
to play if he provokes black to play
Knight g4 then after Bishop h5 and after
for example a line like h6 Bishop h4 g5
it's very funny like in this kind of a
setup it's more often that you might see
the move Knight f6 to h5 in order to
capture the bishop now that your Knights
on g4 it's not bothering anybody and the
next move will be a move like f3 and
just chase it back so and in the
meantime black has weakened his King
side structure there are many many many
ways for white to play against the perk
defense which is one of the reasons I
ended up in Banda nning it myself was
because I just got tired of dealing with
a wide wide variety of formations that
white could choose as it turns out Yvan
shuck chose what is called the classical
variation of the perk or what is more
appropriately
the Geller variation Knight f3 Bishop g7
Bishop e2 it's a it's also this setup
for white is also called the quiet
system so the idea of the quiet system
is just as it sounds why doesn't making
any great pretensions of blowing black
away with some vigorous attack rather
he's simply saying okay I'm just
developing what are you doing now again
from a Vladimir's point of view there
are many ways for for black to equalize
a very standard move here is move like
Bishop g4 'if I've comes into mind uh I
like as black in this system I like to
play the move c7 c6 which is a kind of a
flexible move asking white what he wants
to do and in time I often played the
move also c6 with the idea of b5 and
after for example a for to stop the move
b5 a move like Knight d7 and in K so for
example a move like Bishop f4 I want to
play as black the movie 75 and I like
this idea of Queen a5 supporting ePHI
than playing for a 5 and I think black
is just fine in my younger days I also
played a 6 h3 and this move knight c6 I
had tried this against Grand Master
Larry Christensen and in this particular
I actually did it a move earlier I had
played knight c6 against Larry and
others a new variation and the idea is
that after the move d5 what do you think
black should play
nice and black should play night if you
I made a mistake of playing Knight to e5
and after the trade the swap I never
really got a very good King side attack
going
I ended up playing moves like Knight d8
f5 and 96 but actually against Patrick
wolf and other grandmasters it played
night be eight which is very cool
essentially what I've said is I just
provoked you to advance your pawns and
if you do a move like h3 I'll play c6
and if you do a move for example like
Bishop e3 I'll play Knight B d7 and in
some cases my idea might be to play
Knight c5 and go after this pawn on e4
okay so all of this is kind of it goes
to show the extraordinary flexibility of
the of the position but a6 I liked h3
now I'm not a hundred percent sure about
this move knight c6 with this move h3
basically what white is saying is please
I want you to play the move b5 question
to my audience why didn't he play b5
what's I mean isn't the in you know
isn't the intention of the move a six to
play b5 now with the move b5 you got
this tremendous threat of b4 Knight
takes e4 and get yourself all excited so
what is wrong with a move B v e5 and
what happens for example after D takes
e5
don't all shout out at once
in truth white has two favorable
captures first of all after the move
pawn takes e5 Knight d7 attacking the
pawn on e5 e6 is a very standard and
very powerful idea for black for white
white sacrifices upon and threatens to
recapture the pawn on e6 and threatens
Bishop f3 equally good for white is that
in this move it in this position after E
5 takes also a very good capture is
Knight takes e5 with just the very
simple idea of like you've weakened this
long diagonal I want to play Bishop here
to f3 and to try to conquer this square
in some way so this too is a very
favorable position for white and that
was why vladimir went for knight c6 now
bishop came to g5 b v a3 h6 bishop here
and we get to what i think is the first
extremely critical position of the game
on the surface
nothing special seems to be happening
but dig a little bit deeper and very
important things have happened first of
all on the Queen side this advance of a6
and b5 which provoked this response a3
is very favorable for black this is very
very nice for black like you see it in a
lot of Sicilians right where a 6 b5 is
played and whenever boy I'm shaky
I think air conditioning or something
when when white is provoked to playing
a3
pack is very happy because this advanced
pawn on b5 control some important
squares and you're not really afraid
about the move a for undermining the
Queen site because that will cost white
attempt so that's the first thing that's
happening and that's very very favorable
for black the second thing that's
happened as we all understand the
classical pawn strip a classical pawn
center and the strengths of the positive
we like holding the classical pawn
center but in some ways what you're
doing when you have the classical pawn
center is you're controlling the center
squares
very good you're occupying the center
and your your pieces behind the advanced
center can be nicely developed yay so
that's why we like having the pawns in
the center but on the other hand these
two bishops are very effective on e 3
and E 2 so even though you have your
advanced pawn center and your pieces are
sitting behind the pawns in reality
these pieces are not very effective and
one of the reasons why they're not very
effective is because blacks setup is
actually quite flexible there's a very
important understanding of pawn
structures and the flexible pawn
structure so this is actually a crucial
position how many of you think that
white is better how do you think
positions roughly speaking even okay how
many of you prefer black okay I actually
happen to like black in this position
and I would always play this Pasiphae
ponents agreed before the game and we
get this position I would think that
black has
improve this position from move one why
let's adjust in the game Vladimir plate
'if I've and I would give this move a
question mark as in a nearly decisive
error whoa that strong words right I'm
nearly decisive error one of the things
as we look at the position just kind of
briefly for a second is we have to say
that in a kind of a teensy-weensy to
little bit of way White's development
he's ahead and development in his
developments a little superior when
you're behind in development you never
open the position full stop
you just never open the position so
before you open the position make sure
that you are properly developed so let
me play a game with my audience for a
moment and here what I would have
strongly recommended and what I would
have played is the movie 76 why would I
play this move well in a sense what I'm
doing is I'm blocking White's path I'm
you know like when he moves his pawns
forwards I can move my pieces out of the
way with the movie 76 I'm saying to you
white player what are you doing in my
mind's eye if you give me two three
moves with black I'm going to play on my
bishop on b7 so I'm on the long diagonal
which will make my bishop more effective
than yours I'm going to play Bishop b7
I'll tell you I kind of give you a I
show my cards I'm going to play Bishop
d7 and my next move after that as I'm
going to play knight on c6 to e7 and I'm
going to attack your pawn now I would
love for you to advance your your Center
for example this would probably be a big
mistake on your part after E 5 D takes
e5 let's just say D takes e5 just so I
can make my point
well you just pushed your pawn right
into the teeth of my defense my
intention is to capture your pawn so
let's say instead you picked up what you
might consider a very nice tempo what
could be sweeter and then developing
your pieces with a gain of time so you
play Queen d2 you attack my pawn on h6
which is similar to the game by the way
not exactly what happened in the game
Vladimir plays King h7 so more or less
this is a starting position after what
I'm suggesting was a very good move by
black which is e six now how I just toss
out some moves to from my audience how
would you play if you were white would
you develop your rook yay would you
advance your pawns maybe not what moves
do you like for white
very good so now what the gentleman has
just suggested was to reposition the
knight on f3 which is a very interesting
point he makes a very very deep
observation with these pawns in the
center it's not enough
one idea from whites point of view would
be to go Knight H 2 followed by f4 to
bring out a greater tension in the
center right to 2 to bring more fire
force in the center but then I could
transpose into what Vladimir did and I
provoked your knight away from the
center so we're going to see the game in
a moment but I'm saying the move Knight
H 2 is very good if you do nothing if
you just do a kind of a rote kind of
development if you played rook on a 1 to
D 1 let's say Bishop b7 and really if
you look at the classical text books the
so-called Fred Reinfeld school of chess
you know all the whites pieces are in
the center yay but how effective and on
all of black's pieces seem to be on the
flanks strengthening on the flanks but
how effective are White's pieces for
example after the move 97
well you've opened up this bishop if the
pawn advances to e5 well now you control
the d5 square if you play a move like
Bishop d3 okay you're kind of taking the
defensive right if you advance the pawn
to d5 that will cost you a pawn if you
advance the pawn to e5 again I'm just
going to take the square this is a very
flexible
situation for kramnik and it's the ideal
that he was wanting he wants to give
Evon check an opportunity to think if
you go to the deep deep deep think and
lose on time
and also what Kramnik really wants is to
lengthen the game and to play a long
long game and hopefully to keep his
chances for victory alive okay so in my
opinion this was the first critical
position of the game and Vladimir I
don't want to say blunder but it makes
an egregious error with this movie Phi
because white now ready to with a
superior slightly superior development
is ready for battle okay and the
following sequence that the players
played is nearly forced first of all
again when we're ahead of development
what we should be trying to do is get a
thick structure because we're not in a
thick structure first of all it's very
easy for us to imagine that what what it
is that we would like to do so fixing
the structure right aways it to whites
advantage secondly what's really a
problem is if we look at this position
remember how I said the pawns on end on
a six and B five our big advantage in
relaxed favor right and it's true but
that pawn on b5 has a small drawback
what's the drawback of the pawn on d5
yes that's exactly right after you've
played the move b5 you lose a little bit
of control over the square c5 but on the
other hand you say that's not a problem
because my pawn on d6 defends the c5
square took oops after E 5 takes takes
there's no defense of the pawn to the
square c5
now the c5 square is almost like a
magnet for whites pieces white could
easily imagine for example transferring
the knight to c5 via a route like Knight
d2 Knight B 395 of course in that case I
would occupy d4 but as Vasiliy points
out so it demonstrates clearly after
move Queen c1 with the tempo against h6
King here Bishop c5 attacking the rook
vladimir makes a second mistake his
first mistake was a 5 the second mistake
comes now so with the move Bishop c5
attacking this rook on f8 the rook gotta
move
vladimir played rook e8 and falls into a
nightmarish position a very bad position
so the problem is we'll find out in a
moment is well why is the move rook e8
bad well in truth the rook actually
occupies a square that the Queen needs
Vladimir had to play the move rook g8 ok
so after the move rook g8 if we follow
the game for just a moment
rook d1 was the move that Yvonne sure
played as white now with the rook on e8
the Queen of course is trapped and
Vladimir had to walk into a self pin the
bishop had to come to d7 here he has the
opportunity of playing Queen e8 oops
well that wasn't the the opportunity ah
Queen e8 okay so now why is this
very very different from the game well
in the game
Vladimir got his pieces all kind of
pinned up and cramped I still prefer
White's position but at least in my
mind's eye from blacks point of view
what black would like to do is he would
like to position his bishop on the long
diagonal Bishop to b7 and maybe one day
play Knight to d4 have a lot of trades
on the d4 square and then play Knight
takes e4 the rook on g8 is stupid no
it's just stupid we agree there's no
question it's a stupid rook but on the
other hand the rook on e8 is just as
equally stupid and at some moment after
I play Bishop b7 I may also consider
ideas of Queen e6 and just simply
playing rook to d8 in other words even
though the rook on g8 is offsides it's a
temporary let's see what happened in the
game oops Bishop c5 rook e8 rook d1
Bishop d7 and now we get the now we get
the feeling or now we start to
understand then actually blacks position
is in deep doo-doo this isn't this is a
big square this is control of the big
square Bishop c5 White's rook is already
on the Open File open D file the bishop
is in a pin from White's point of view
if it was white to move Y could play
move like Queen e3 everything is
harmonious there's going to be no attack
against the h3 pawn because the bishop
could draw it back and in the meantime
after a move like Queen e3 you got to
start to worry about a4 b4 and 95 and
all of whites pieces just flow it just
it's all good for white vladimir is in
trouble
this move be for it wasn't my first
I didn't I didn't think this move was
bad I didn't think it was the best move
actually in my opinion the best move was
a very straight forward move and that
was Queen III and in case for example
the game position it's kind of
transpositional after queen c8 Black has
to start to worry about a move like a 4b
495 now keep in mind in this type of a
position there are never any sacrifices
here Bishop takes h3g takes h3 Queen
takes h3 walks into the discovere check
Knight g5 check and I take your queen
thank you for coming please sign my
score sheet and as we can see White's
forces are better geared or more
directed into the center and by the way
if white does get his chance he can now
continue with the idea of Bishop c4 and
then all of his forces are working in
harmony and blacks army is just where is
the harmony okay but I really did
understand this move b4 the idea behind
the move before is as straightforward as
it looks white wants to play a four
create a weakness on the Queen side but
deny but to deny black the opportunity
of playing b5 before okay so
everything's kind of going nicely Queen
see a queen e3 probably probably very
quickly no Bishop takes h3 sacrifices
that's it that's already dealt with and
now Vladimir doesn't have an active plan
I mean what can latter mare do with this
pieces it's never it's never a good idea
to jump into the center 94 Knight takes
d4 a takes d4 rook takes d4 or Bishop
takes d4 I take
pawn for free what do you got you know
he just blundered upon if black moves
his LightSquared Bishop to say the e6
square well how are you going to deal
with a for creating a queen side
weakness um Julian yes exactly so one of
the that this is a very standard idea
from what from blacks point of view is
to play Knight h5 and Knight f4 which in
fact Latimer did he did it and at a
later date but let's analyze just
briefly an idea like Knight h5 okay so
if I'm white I'm really happy that
you're going to the side of the board
right like just keep going look like
here go as far as you like to the side
of the board you play on the wing I play
through the center I've got two ideas
the first idea is I still like this move
a for a lot if you take it okay if you
take on a four I win control of the
square c4 also in my mind's eye I'm
thinking that you may play your knight
here again with ideas of sacrificing
over here my intention is to meet the
move Knight f4 with the move Bishop f1
defending I'm going to kick your night
away so then if I'm playing a four with
the attention of damaging your pawn
structure winning the square c4 for my
Bishop well if I want to meet Knight f4
with Bishop f1 maybe I don't need to
remove a four I like to move a four but
even a more interesting idea I think
from White's point of view is how are
you going to meet the move Knight d5
again you play on the Kings side I play
through the center let's suggest that
Julian's intention
was night F for a reasonable idea and
let's suggest that I'm a greedy guy and
I want to win upon hey I want a bond
what are you gonna do about it yes
Bravo there's somebody is alert I want
to take York exactly you take my rook
yay anybody guess what I'd like to do
remember I'm an old pond grubber
so I give him give you a heads up yeah
you bet Queen takes f7 oh by the way
Jack excellent move anybody suggesting
what I would like to do pigs these are
you bad
give me that rook give me that bishop so
now exactly in this position I have two
ponds and a bishop for an exchange but
that's not all your king is seriously
under siege if you defend the bishop on
g7 with the move of jean didn't did you
guys ever hear me say about rook g8 you
could have been a temple ahead you know
if you played rook g8 that our rook e8
if you play now the move rook g8 you've
got a real issue after rook takes e7
attacking your Queen attacking your
knight winning a third pawn for the
exchange basically black is being
brutalized right so after the move
Knight d5 you are not playing the move
Knight f4 and instead of playing a four
I start to conceive another idea I start
to conceive that maybe I should play c4
and after you change I'm going to take
with a bishop and then again you see
this harmony all of whites pieces are
going going through the center this
Bishop is good this Bishop is okay this
Bishop is basically
well it's one-dimensional this night is
not really working this night is kind of
being dominated for the moment by this
knight on d5
so Vladimir already in some trouble
really found his only move he played my
d8 okay and I always explain this to the
people I don't my opponents pieces are
going back I'm happy here I can go back
as far as you like you know if you want
to put them on the 9th rank that'll suit
me just fine
so black finds literally the only chance
in the position with this redeployment
now just because my opponents pieces are
going back I shouldn't be overly happy
at least we can conceive for black that
if he is able to bring his knight to e6
he could then bring it to f4 as Julian
would like and then you know there are
some real tempting sacrifices over here
so white has to play accurately he
launches a 4b takes a four Knight takes
a four knight c6 Bishop c4 so there's
been a kind of a flow and so so far so
good
Knight f5 well a knight h5 of course one
problem from blacks point of view is if
you bring your knight here to the f4
square thanks to this Bishop being on c4
you have to worry about Bishop takes f7
so okay so Bishop c4 Knight H Knight f5
and it was very interesting to hear the
players interviewed after the game at
this moment Vladimir felt his position
was okay there was this moment that I
really didn't like his position at all
it was like wow you know like what I
mean I respect Vladimir he's an
extraordinarily
the player but I really thought that
white is for choice Knight c3 very very
standard move now that blacks Queen side
structure is split this Knight has done
its job this pawn on a6 is weak and the
knight is floating back to the center
now I got 495 Bishop b5 and Bishop b3
just a second I think there was this
moment how many of you have seen the
game between Anatoly Karpov and I forgot
his first name moons occur on Zickuhr
this is a very famous game in the Rui
Lopez and Nigel short he likes to talk
about this game and he says that his
favorite move is from the game between
Karpov and moons occur and Karpov made a
move that was very very celebrated
around the world and anybody familiar
with that game
it's okay say no that's alright good
good good good good good it's even
better that you don't know the move
so what moves if you were white would
you conceive of in this position yes sir
excellent move that's an excellent move
you bring your knight to the center
again what the Vladimir play Knight here
night here and he did play Knight to d5
so you play like Vladimir Kramnik what
can you say you know some guys have it
but that's not Karpov smooth so what
besides the move Knight d5 which is a
magnet of course what else could like
play Alex
Bishop takes a six so Bishop takes a six
why doesn't this lose something well
let's see yeah well alex is a chess
coach chess trainer so he will explain
all about removing the defender so
Bishop takes a six rook takes a six rook
takes a 6 mm what what what I tell me
tell me
Knight takes e5 so Bishop takes h3 ideas
like Bishop takes g2 Queen g4 most
likely vessel Yvan Chuck wanted to avoid
this yeah but power to you Alex because
you're on the right track you would like
in in the beautiful fantasy land if you
take away this black rook just take it
off the board the move Bishop takes a6
is a killer
because the Queen defends the bishop on
d7 and the whole game just collapses
well the camus game was between carp
often and moons occur was that it was a
royal Lopez and the a file was open so
wide had a rook on a1 and black had a
rook on a8 and what white did was white
played the move Bishop Karpov played the
move Bishop on e3 to a7 and what car
pause idea was was that he could then
follow it up with rook a5 rook a1
doubling on the a file and then
retreating his Bishop and then Karpov
wins control over the only open rank and
he won and and Nigel short prescribes is
his favorite move in chess Bishop a7 so
imagine that
imagine that Vasiliy had played this
move Bishop a set and at first you kind
of like that's a very strange move but
if you look at it for greater than two
seconds well your next turn is Bishop
takes a sex not only winning a pond but
lots and lots and lots of issues are
going over here for black again I
suspect that he didn't do this because
it moves like Knight takes G to King
takes G to night Jack King H to Bishop
takes h3 and and vastly so why do I even
have to do that but in fact those
attacks are not threatening
so Bishop a7 would have won material and
the funny thing is is after you know
like I'm an I'm commentating the game
and so forth and so on after the game
was over I put it in my computer the
first move the computer looks at as
Bishop a7 White's up by one one in the
half on this is like human players don't
play it computer say hey that's a that's
a winner Knight d5 very very standard
Bishop b5 Bishop b3 not not trading
bishops and and the Pope the pawns are
split the trade of Bishops means the
pawns are not split
okay so Bishop to c6 so why did Latimer
play Bishop b5 and now Bishop c6 well
very clearly had he played Bishop c6
immediately that would have meant that
this pawn is attacked
so first Bishop b5 and
Oh bishop c6 okay rook a5 so White's
just building up behind his superior
pawn structure and at the same time he's
basically saying to black okay what are
you going to do for a movie you're going
to take my night and then sacrifice over
here with Knight take g2 what are you
going to do
Vladimir Kramnik like Queen b7 and now
this very strange move g3 after the game
it was very interesting to listen to the
comments of the players both players
thought that this was absolutely normal
and natural to play the move g3 and to
sacrifice the pawn and really causes a
black angst I'm a pawn grubber I don't
believe in giving away nothing no what
are you talking about I thought that the
move King h2 was very strong I like
White's position with the idea like if
it's my move I would play moves like c4
and g3 in fact if we go back a move I
actually the move rook a5 is fine but I
actually also thought the move King H to
preparing g3 was also a very nice
position for white but ok so these moves
get played g3 black wins upon Knight
goes back to g5 rook comes over to h1
King goes back all of these moves were
played rather rapidly I think both
players were less on time but I think
Yvonne check perhaps a little bit more
so Ivonne Chuck has won upon a von
Schaack has deliberately sacrificed upon
but more importantly look at the
position white this Bishop is very nice
this Bishop is very nice this
is better than this night this rook is
more active than that rook this Queen on
e3 if effectively attacks more squares
and then the Queen on b7 and so forth
and so on
but even having said all of that
remarkably enough the position is still
anybody's game
I think all three results are possible
here I think that white is better but
not by let's say any decisive amount I
was f2 f3 okay a little bit just you
know reinforcing this pawn on e4 which
in reinforces this knight on d5 but this
move was a big surprise for me Bishop
takes c6 Bishop c6 takes d5 I you know
when you're a pawn up you're supposed to
trade yes sir yes knight on d5 to e7
check that is the whole point of the
move f3y wants to play this move the
problem is is that the pawn on e4 is
weak so that after rook takes e7 Bishop
takes e7 Bishop takes e4 check wins back
the rook on the diagonal so the move f2
f3 is in fact essentially set up for
that move Knight isse Evan check so
Bishop takes c6 I wasn't really a big
fan of this move like there are other
moves in this position that black could
entertain and I still wasn't a hundred
percent sure you know like how to fully
evaluate the position 90s but okay
Bishop takes Bishop takes c6 this isn't
a bad idea and after Bishop here this
move Queen ca
also struck me as very strange in the
first place I'm not a hundred percent
sure well the night on g5 I mean I was
always taught centralized your nights
right and equally I was taught you know
centralize your rook centralized
everything so I thought that the
position after night on e6 Knight to e6
pardon me it's still anybody's game if
you allow black the opportunity either
take this bishop or perhaps to jump to
the square d4
okay your pawn up so I was surprised by
this move Queen c8 which I thought was
kind of strange and the move Queen b3 I
really related to I like this move a lot
from White's point of view first of all
you not only are putting some very very
serious pressure on the f7 pawn what I
liked was the idea that now I could
redeploy this Bishop to e3 and capture
this Knight now Vladimir's position
really started to sink fast h5 well we
understand that move we understand that
white wants to play Bishop e3 and he
doesn't want it spawn on h6 hanging
right Bishop e3 night II 6 rook H 1 D 1
here I think time trouble nerves
something Vladimir really I think to
simply panicked here and he came up with
this move h4 which I think that that
just mm well kind of just blows the game
let's put it like that blows the game
okay White's winning back is pong okay
you know this sort of like good for you
you get to win back your pawn but it
doesn't mean that you know I should
resign or something like this
my problem what I really want to do is I
do want to play this move Knight d4 but
I have a problem on f7 so I need to
release I need to cover the pawn on d7 I
thought after the move Queen d7 or even
a move like rookie 7 either Queen d7 or
rookie 7 if we see a trade-in on the one
hand I'm kind of happy is black with
this exchange because remember White's
rooks are really kind of dama
let's rook on aah doing nothing well now
I got rid of my rook okay so now after
something like this I thought okay 94
Queen comes to a2 and now I've got this
issue with rook a8 that I have to deal
with what was I thinking there was a
line of play here no that's sorry it's
not with this line of play it's with
Queen on d7 I power part I apologize
we're just going to go back for a moment
Queen to d7 and what was this it was
stuff now I'm not sure I can remember
the line I was getting some play here
how can I get some play hmm
what was I think there was some line
where I was getting some play help me up
what am I missing
help me out hmm I can't recall their Sun
if maybe it's Queen d1 mm-hmm oh boy
okay something went wrong this second
now I did it now I've done it wrong here
yeah oh okay so it was c6 Bishop here
okay Queen CA okay so right so now so
not was it this was the line where I
think I was asking for 96
I apologize right so this line was
different because what what would you
recommend for white after the move
Knight e6 any takers Bishop takes a 6 ok
but after rook takes c6 at some point
you might redirect your energies you
might play rook d1 Queen e2 and you you
might win that pawn back that in that
case I've got a problem with this bishop
with my Queen still on b7 I'm thinking
that I could play h5 and Bishop here and
black chances of making a draw seem
exceptionally reasonable to me I don't
see any reason why black should be
especially unhappy about that position
so I apologize I think it was here where
this move Queen c8 I think that this was
a wasted move Queen b3 h5 Bishop e3 and
this is now already where Vlad Amir is
already in trouble because he's not
getting the counter play
the kingside as fast as white is playing
what takes a six and so on so here I
thought Vladimir was in deep trouble he
played h4 which I also thought was wrong
I think I had a different idea here for
Vladimir not that it's a anything great
but I thought that Vladimir should play
a very interesting strange move I
thought bladder Mayer should play King
here new variation so what's the idea
the idea is in case white goes for this
capture capture capture variation I
think it was Bishop here so here at
least I'm trying to create counter play
my bishop on g7 hasn't been doing
anything so now I'm trying to get my
bishop in the game with Bishop g7 to h6
and a follow up with the move H 5 H 4 I
thought that this was the way that
Vladimir had to go instead he played
this move H 4 oops excuse me if there is
any any questions let me know G takes H
for Queen d8 rook takes a6 and now this
move was really surprising because not
only does it lose a tempo but it
consigns the rook on c8 to playing the
defensive role of the pawn on the a6 and
it allows us look on a 6 to live in and
now with this move rook h1 Vasily
basically says well I've got an extra
defender on the King side and that guy's
not playing and here at this point
actually I think vastly just played
literally perfect you just you just shut
down blacks counter play I didn't see
anything
this is really nice - okay one in the
back - yes
and this first of all sorry after the
move b5 the problem from blacks point of
view of course is he would love to take
this pawn but after rook takes pawn
takes Queen takes check this rook is
actually now playing suddenly in an
attacking role with this move h5 in the
works
not to mention g6 is hanging so rook
here b6 incredibly powerful passed pawn
c5 trying to rip b1 defending the pawn
on d6 Bishop f8 Queen d5 it's been a
it's strange that it just seemed to me
that white literally played the whole
game basically in blacks camp right I
mean all of the I mean with the with the
single exception of this short-lived
excursion to the f4 square by the Black
Knight I mean it's been White's pieces
that have always been held forward and
it was like as you said in this
interview like Vladimir and especially
after the game Vladimir thought his
position was okay whereas it just seems
to me that life is like had everything
the whole way through now it's now it
was easy for Yvonne Chuck he could
calculate the finish and this move what
you were saying Ben that's really nice
it goes rook H Ron look on a 1 to h1
rook on h1 to be one and then back to a1
and he's threatening to play the obvious
rook a8 pinning the bishop to the King
followed by Bishop takes e5 and it's
resigns rook d6
rook a8 this was quite easily for easy
for Vasily to cat to calculate basically
if you capture this pawn rook takes b6
you've got no defense after the move
rook a8 the threats of Bishop takes e5
or more simply rook takes FA check
xf8 and Bishop takes e5 winning so
Bishop d6 rook a six now I think at this
moment magnus carlsen he had a losing
position against Peter Svidler having
made the time control and he had gone
over to look at the game this game and
you know how do you say reassured
himself that not even Yvonne
checkerboard miss you know like it made
the dyeing control and it's very easy
from White's point of view what hit
white wants to do is just bring his King
to the support of the b6 pawn and just
bringing us King straight up and it's
it's gone you can't save this position
and so here that absolutely flattered me
resign this was this was some tournament
I don't think we're going to see a
tournament is exciting and it's
compelling viewing as this one for many
many years